oh yeah happy Tuesday everybody it's
great to see every one of you except for
you over there
so once again protesters attacked
expensive pieces of Art and no I'm not
talking about my quads
though they are pricey and worth it this
time it's an Andy Warhol in Milan Italy
on Friday the attention-seeking freaks
threw flour on a sports car painted by
the pop artist in 1979 pop artist
fortunately the Italian police sprang
into action and formed it into a pizza
crust foreign
but the event the event is just another
in a trend by Young psychotics Who
vandalize art with food or paint
although such actions might improve a
Jackson Pollock
little art humor there
for all you sophisticated and does
anybody else find it ironic that one
piece of art they don't throw soup on is
this one
because it's redundant now every time we
report on this I get a little angry but
then again I'm five foot five so what
other kind of angry can I get but the
whole point but I am but the whole point
of this vandalism is to get suckers like
me to report on their cause so let's
ignore the cause and focus yeah yes
I don't even know what it is I don't
know what it is instead let's focus on
the freaks who destroy their cause with
each stunt they win over no one for
every painting they attack I'll eat
another cow
hell I might even push one out of my
coal powered jet
it's gonna be great they sound they make
when they land yeah but the big story
here it's not just gender that's no
longer binary it's sanity
those people breaking these laws appear
to be certifiable look at them their
Madness personified they're sad and
they're gross if they didn't spend their
time throwing vegan corn chowder on Mona
Lisa's they'd have no lives at all
[Music]
the old days they'd be carted off placed
in comfy cells with padded walls Cat
knows what I'm talking about
you know thank God I helped her get
straight
you're welcome cat
but now they're not even bum rushed by
security judging by how little effort
these guards make you think they weren't
protecting a Warhol but this
I could draw binky
in fact you gotta wonder if these aren't
inside jobs I mean who lets people into
a gallery while they're carrying
containers of flour or paint cans not
that art museum guards should be SEAL
Team Six but if you see a bunch of nose
ring green hairs carrying bags a flower
or Kansas soup or paint you can bet they
aren't there to smile back at the Mona
Lisa
and Sanity used to be easily defined but
now we redefined unstable Behavior as
passionate but you know who else was
passionate about the environment Charles
Manson and his passionate family of
human scum
before we used to look at these people
and say well that's one point of view
now relax while some men in white coats
chase you with a giant butterfly net
remember those Nets those are great now
it's wow they're so dedicated let's hear
them out they must really believe in
this cause to scream in strangers faces
and smear poop on the walls
or maybe they're just getting ready to
host Jesse Waters prime time
that's all you need to do
the mercy of scammers and mentally
damaged people these are desperate
isolated Souls with no real sense of the
world and they're gaining traction Joe
Biden and his Pals at the U.N climate
conference disagreed to pay up to one
billion dollars in so-called climate
reparations to poor Nations for damage
apparently caused by the West fossil
fuel use
yeah let's apologize for raising the
standard of living for 90 percent of the
human population on the planet and be
punished by the 10 who couldn't keep up
sorry world for the AC the combustion
engine irrigation system sewage
treatment plants dishwashers electricity
so here's a couple billion while you
continue to burn things far worse than
coal and here's the kicker the world's
biggest emitter doesn't have to pay a
dime
and no not Eric swalwell
it's communist China and why because
it's still considered a developing
Nation yeah that makes real sense
calling China a developing nation is
like calling Dolly Parton a developing
female
but let's face it China's smarter than
us they don't buy into this Progressive
they don't see sex as non-binary as a
matter of fact they see the world as
binary as the computer technology they
steal from us they see the world as ones
and zeros and they're the ones and
everybody else are zeros and they laugh
at us for falling for this crap
so we've now embraced Insanity as an
alternative lifestyle it's the
elimination of Standards the destruction
of beauty whether it's an art or one's
own body activists destroy Priceless
paintings as easily as they butcher
their own healthy bodies it's like our
society is experiencing a sort of a
mental illness as a whole
before if someone can participate in
civilized life we'd get them help now we
can't even say who's mentally ill at all
which might be the new definition of
crazy
and most of this stuff is coming out of
tick tock and who owns that China it's a
brilliant strategy destroy from within
by giving the vacuous West exactly what
they can't resist attention
[Applause]
let's welcome
tonight's Gus she left the sidelines but
still dumps Gatorade on people just for
fun most of the sideline sanity podcast
Michelle taboya
[Applause]
his show is the reason thieves no longer
steal car radios Osa Fox Across America
Jimmy Fallon
he's such a great father he made sure
his kids have two thanksgivings
to a writer and comedian Jamie lissau
[Applause]
don't kill me Jamie and you can use your
elbows to carve your turkey Fox News
contributor cartoon
[Applause]
Michelle it's so you know we we do these
stories a lot about these crazy people
but it really I think the bigger story
is that we don't call them crazy I you
know what these people remind me a lot
of the people I knew or saw on campus at
Berkeley and you and I were both there
there were a lot of passionate people
there as well look when you do stupid
stuff you look stupid and when you look
stupid no one takes you seriously and
when no one takes you seriously you
don't gain their allyship in fact you
lose a lot of people I feel like that's
what these people are doing as for this
un climate reparations
the UN is the most useless body on the
planet yeah
saying that you're saying that in front
of Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy I didn't say that Jimmy he did but
think about the U.N security Council two
permanent members two permanent members
of the U.N security Council are China
and the Russian Federation yeah I mean
when you think of that you ask yourself
what is the U.N I went on the UN website
today and this one headline was UN
stability signs or something and I
unstability yes yes I mean it's it's
it's insane these reparations are stupid
who's gonna who's gonna decide how much
and which countries and who did what and
which scientist is going to determine
which climate change thing led to this
it's all like this massive virtue signal
and no science behind it am I afraid am
I allowed to say I just I hate the u.net
I think it's more dangerous to say I
love the U.N
that box yeah
Amy good to see you you look like you
haven't slept in a while okay that's
what I'm going for yeah it's funny we do
really have two thanksgivings really
since the divorce because that way my
wife can be grateful she doesn't have to
look at my face anymore it makes sense
you know what I mean yes um these
activists are entertaining I don't
relate to them at all throwing food on
things gluing themselves to different
you know whatever different uh
presentations at Museum pieces or
whatever I don't relate to this at all
like I would rather that you glued me to
the sidewalk so I didn't have to go to
the art museum
that's what I was like did you see the
name I feel like this was like a joke
given to us but the name of the activist
group was last generation which I saw
him no one's banging these girls
it is true but you know what what kills
me about them they could be attractive
but they're they they hate all like you
know patriarchal standards of beauty
when in fact it happened before
patriarchy we just like symmetry we like
attractive things we like paintings and
they hate that yeah and you're right and
also like if throwing the food on the
car like I feel like if Andy Warhol had
put flour on the car people would have
been like oh we like your new thing you
made yes it would cost 80 million
dollars yeah they would think it was
part of the thing I feel like abstract
art in general was invented when Picasso
went how can I get some money for this I
did when I was three
it's actually a fair point I mean it's
really hard to destroy that stuff it's
kind of like your shirt oh you stop yes
I actually look like a stripper who gets
paid in stuffing
this is embarrassing I'd say you put the
duty in howdy Duty I'll just take it I'm
just gonna take it I came up with that
in the green room I was pretty proud of
it got you a poop joke that's kind of
clean that's so unlike you yes I'll be
talking about cab driving yeah go ahead
tell us what you think well in all
honesty it was nice to see a painter
covered in white powder besides Hunter
Biden
there you go
but what's so ridiculous about this is
they're doing it in an art museum where
everyone in the museum presumably agrees
with them there's nothing more left-wing
than a modern art museum right you're
not preaching to the choir you're
flowering the choir you know what I'm
saying no it's true in fact the majors
generally the majors for leftists are
art history yeah think about that like
imagine you were like protesting the
pro-life movement at the Lilith Fair
yeah
board and to your point no one's banging
those chicks either so there you go
pro-choice thank you yes you got me yes
I got you I wanted to save it can I not
save it it was kind of like in between
because the point is they're protesting
first thing everybody agrees with yes so
it's a little convoluted cat
if people from like you know when they
always talk about time traveling if you
time traveled from the year 2000 you
would be freaked out by now because it
seems like we have people openly
destroying art we have mobs stealing and
never getting punished for it you have
men who identify as women attacking
women you it's it's like what is going
on here it to me they could all be under
the same umbrella that we've allowed
ourselves to abdicate the definition of
Sanity what say you lady in white I feel
like there's been a lot of
misguided
shaming and slamming of unstable
Behavior
because unstable behavior is not always
bad yeah it can be effective in what way
oh come on live a little uh that's my
they're seeing the main issue with these
kids is that they're unstable it's not
it's that it didn't work there was
actually an article that was like here's
a list of all the art that climate
activists have tried to destroy this
year and there's a lot of scrolling
involved in that list but for just one
example I had a guy that break up broke
uh broke up with me he broke with me a
lot but this one was really sticking
okay
so and he had me blocked on all the
things but then there was of course my
secret account so I found out that he'd
be performing somewhere I showed up in
the neighborhood looking super hot was
that stable no did he call me the next
day yes oh so we got back together that
was effective for the goodness of my own
life ultimately not but these kids
aren't like when Biden did this he
wasn't like you know why I did this it
was those hipster soup kids uh they're
doing all this stuff and it's not even
effective for what they want it to be
and they should be able to realize that
by now why do you think Biden is doing
it then for the reparation someone the
same as he does everything somebody told
him yes yes listen thank you
[Applause]
good answer producer make it sound like
I said that
they could do that now they just change
the voice that's great I get all the
best jokes sorry guys hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else